declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic in accordance with
house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is
authorized to meet electronically this
is an executive session
on bill's report referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary to participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and
rsa 91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call area
code 603-271-3600
or email h c
s ledge l e g
dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
please note that all votes will be taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote let's start the meeting
by taking roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is a
requirement under the right to know law
and clark will you call the
representative expedia here there's no
one else in the room either
representative frost
i'm present and there's no one in the
room with me currently representative
greene
i'm here at lob in the room
representative hill i am here also
in the llb room 306.
representative lay i am here in ridge
new hampshire in my office and there is
no one here with me
representative mckinney here hello
representative nutting wong i'm here
i'm in my home in nashua alone
representative osborne
uh here alone in my office in concord
representative packard
representative richards
can't hear representative richard your
[Music]
muted
i can't hear you at all we'll work on
that
damn are you um
i think it's something on representative
richard's end i don't know
she's not muted i can see that she's
talking um
sometimes just simply getting out of the
program and coming back in
can can help and it's worth a try okay
um moving on from representative richard
i don't remember
that representative ruler
she was here she was here
um uh the clerk is here in the lob
representative simon here in the lobby
representative smith president from my
home office in manchester and i am alone
representative wall here of the lb 306.
so we're missing uh representative
packard and our representative
right and representative richards has
come back maybe we can
test her sound can you hear me now
yes yes
thank you i'll keep an eye out for
representative
yard um by phone and bring her in when
she
uh comes um
pam did we have any indication
for a substitute for uh representative
packard
i have not received anything no
representative osborne do you know
anything more than
we do sitting here
no i do not
um can you give a quick buzz over to
speaker's office and see if they are
aware
i'm gonna hang on for just a second here
and see what's going on
the plan was is to try to do this fairly
quickly so
we can get everybody back to their daily
lives um i'm not even sure i opened this
executive session
um the plan for me is just
go a little bit out of order than what's
here
[Applause]
i'd like to start off with uh house bill
which um which will be
uh the one bill that comes along
pretty much it always has since i
neglected to include it in hearings and
an exact session
but um so we'll start out with 186 and
um
okay so why don't we start off um i
would like to
see if i have a motion for up till 186
and i'll recognize
yes i'd like to
[Music]
i'd like to make a motion uh ought to
pass
on hb 187 186
at 90 seconds
second and i would also like to move
amendment
number 4869 h that's pretty easy
wait for me next time um
does everyone have a copy of uh the
amendment to
house bill 186 which is the number
what zero eight six nine page
anyone not have that that can talk about
oh we have rule artifact i think
ruler you are here and you have no one
with you
i am here and i have no one with me and
i sometimes have no internet so
yeah let us know when you're not there
okay okay i'm here
oh yes uh
rep packer you're you're doing by zoom
rather than
in person right we were waiting for you
in person
can't hear you
how's that how now can you hear me
okay yeah i i i will hopefully get over
there but right now i'm doing it by zoom
and you are in the state house alone i'm
in my office alone
so we have a motion
for octopass on house bill 186
as well as a motion uh on
amendment uh zero six eight nine
zero eight zero eight six
would nine like to speak to your
amendment
motion okay so um the amendment to this
bill
deletes section 5 revising the
description of the members
of the legislative youth advisory
committee
it also amends section 8 by requiring a
majority
members of the advisory committee on
marine pictures
to be from the seacoast region
the bill deleted the residency
requirement entirely
and current law requires all of the
members to be from the seacoast
and it also deletes references to joint
healthcare reform
oversight committee in rsj420n
and rsa 126 aaa that had been
inadvertently omitted
in the bill
they get that is there any more
discussion
on the amendment
seeing none i will ask clerk to
call the role on passing on the otp
motion for
the amendment representative greene
yes representative mckinney
yes representative packard
yes representative osborne
yes representative roulard
yes clerk votes yes
representative simon yes representative
wall
yes representative lay
yes representative smith
yes representative frost
yes representative nutting wong
yes representative richards
yes representative espida
yes representative hill yes
so is half passes 15-0
now we have motion on the floor for otpa
is there any discussion on otpa
seeing none
representative green yes
representative mckinney yes
representative packer yes
representative osborne yes
representative ruler yes
clerk votes yes representative simon
yes representative wall yes
representative lay yes
representative smith yes representative
frost
yes representative netting wong
yes representative richards
yes representative expedia
yes representative hill uh yes
uh that closes house bill 186.
uh i'd like to then move to
house bill 277
which is relative determination of the
state of emergency by the legislature
i would wear a motion
from diamond thank you mr chairman
i would like to move uh that we uh i t
also sent me something makes me get
delicious
simon moves itl on house bill 277
is their second
second all seconds
um you're any discussion
representative simon on your motion um
just that we have a strong bipartisan
bill that's come out of another
committee
and this bill has become superb
unnecessary
thank you is there any further
discussion on house bill 277
seeing online will last the clerk
representative green yes representative
mckinney
yes representative packard
yes representative osborne yes
representative clark yes
clerk ots representative simon
yes representative wall yes
representative lay yes
representative smith yes
boss yes representative nutting wong
yes richard
yes representative expedia
yes representative hill yes
hero on house bill 277
um any objection to consent
house bill 277 will be on consent
calendar
moving on to house bill
three two five um
which is relative to the termination of
a state of emergency bicycle resolution
um i would look for a motion from
representative
reed
and my motion is to retain
hospital 325 house bill 325
has been moved to retain
is there a second
seconded by representative simon
representative greene would you like to
speak promotion
yes uh we only have two people testify
in person and hospital street
five testimonies my house clerk and
vincent in which full
of legislative authority cannot be
exercised by simple
one chamber resolution uh to do so it
goes
both prior official precedent
congratulations manual
[Applause]
finances or state resolutions have the
effect of law
so for those who decide removed
there any other discussion on uh
house bill 325
representative smith had his hand up
before me oh
i can't see representative smith's hand
but i will take care
it's there thank you mr chairman um
as was mentioned uh in the memo we got
from the clerk
and from a plain text reading of the
state constitution
um this bill is unworkable as drafted
and
no amount of work over the summer is
going to fix it so i don't see any
reason to retain it
it should be itl thank you
representative i agree with
everything that representative smith
just said it serves no purpose to retain
this bill
um it's unworkable
um and the objections that were raised
or the reasoning that was raised for itl
in the previous bill applies uh equally
well here as well
thank you any other
conversation regarding three two five
um
my only comment on uh house bill 325 is
uh
and the motions to retain is
probably you're correct that it's
superfluous
but it also means uh there's no
there's no factual difference between
killing it now or
killing it in november if that's the
case
and i think any of these uh that may be
retained
are going to be retained for the purpose
of uh
as you call it insurance
while we've talked about the bill that
came out of the other
committee um
there's no way of knowing uh how that
will proceed through the
through the rest of the process and it
may be that
something uh can be uh
can be salvaged or changed or moved and
having a bill to do that i think it
is worthwhile i saw a representative
uh no lay's hand come back up yep
representative blade well thank you mr
chair yeah i'm
i mean i i hear what you're saying but
um
again there's no need to retain the bill
if if the other bill or other approaches
fail
um nothing really would prevent the
uh a representative from resubmitting
another bill
um and if the uh bill
is deemed not to be repetitive or
directly
uh a repeat of the bill that was
defeated this session if such had
happened that decision is made by a
member of this committee i.e the speaker
so i don't really see why you need to
retain this at all
but you know that's that's your choice
so understood
any any further comments questions
seeing
yes representative mckinney
yes representative packard
yes representative osborne
yes representative roulard
yes clerk voties
representative simon yes representative
wall
no representative lay
no representative smith
no representative frost
no representative nunning wong
no representative richards
can't hear your representative
i don't know
expedia no representative hill
yes
eight seven is the vote to retain uh
house bill 325 will be retained
uh now moving on to
house bill 559
relative to state of emergency
declarations um
mr chairman i'd like to move in
expedient to legislate
uh rep mckinney um moves
house bill 559 and expedient to
legislate
is there a second second by
representative wall
is there any comments
further discussion on house bill
559 seeing none
i will ask the clerk to call the roll
representative green yes representative
mckinney
yes representative packard yes
representative osborne yes
representative brular yes uh clerk
voties
representative simon yes representative
wall
representative lay yes representative
smith
yes representative frost yes
representative netting wong yes
representative richards yes
representative expedia
yes representative hill yes
15-0
the vote being 15-0 on house bill
5-5-9 um
consent is would that be fine for
consent is there any objections to
consent
being none
559 will be on instead
is there a comment someone had or is
that
no okay um
moving on we will go to
house bill
three eight nine um
i don't have anyone down
i guess i'll look for a motion from
anyone
for house bill three eight nine
here uh vicer greene would uh move
retain
on house bill 389 this is relative to
the establishment of a joint legislative
emergency executive order
oversight committee during a declared
state of emergency
i hope they don't want license plates
joint legislative emergency executive
order
oversight committee um is there a second
on house bill 389 being retained
i'll second that representative
yes yes
having been moved and seconded i would
look for any further discussion
would you like to speak to emotion so
we have a lot of things already
happening
there fights put it in this way if you
wouldn't see
okay any further discussion on retaining
house bill 389 yes
uh is that representative smith yes
uh thank you mr chairman um similar to
the other one this bill is structurally
flawed
and no amount of work over the summer
can save it there's no reason not to
just itl the bill now
thank you representative smith any
further comments
seeing none sorry about that folks
um new york new york
um seeing none uh
we will ask clerk to call a roll on
house bill
389 motion is to retain
representative green yes representative
mckinney
yes representative packard yes
representative osborne yes
dave roulard yes clerk votes yes
representative simon yes representative
wall
no representative lay no
representative smith nope representative
frost
no representative nunning wong
no representative richards
no representative expedia
no representative hill yes
both the eight seven
bill 389 will be retained
moving on to house bill 280
and the chair will look for a motion
from representative ruler
um thank you i moved to retain house
bill through two eight
zero um
representative ruler moves retain on
house bill 280
is there a second representative
simon seconds um there
would you like to speak to your motion
representative ruler
uh yes thank you uh house bill 280
was not one of the bills that was
included in the memo that was
given to us by um the clerk
and um
[Music]
attorney's fiance i believe
this is a little bit different than some
of the others that we're talking about
state of emergency this deals with the
emergency orders
and it may be very helpful to any
committee that is going to be looking at
these bills at a later time
to include the executive order and
whether or not it should
be um something that should be put in
versus the state of emergency so
i think that this needs to be retained
and looked at
thank you representative anyone
else with further comments discussion
i will ask the clerk
representative green yes representative
mckinney
representative mckinney can't hear you
representative mckinney
i can see you i can't hear you
representative mckinney can you give us
a thumbs up or a thumbs down
mr chairman would you like me to call
her and stop
me uh sure
that would be good i'll try that all
right
you can move along representative
we will come back uh representative
packard
yes representative osborne
yes representative roulard
yes clerk ots representative simon
yes representative wall no
representative lay no representative
smith
no representative frost
no representative nutting wong
no representative richards
representative expedia no
representative hill yes
representative mckinney um
representative hill
i just spoke with her on the phone and
and as we suspected she could not hear
us
and and we all knew we could not hear
her so she
thought she she'd um leave the meeting
and come back in and hopefully
um reset herself so
that was her plan i think she just
popped back in i didn't
i didn't see her completely leave i
started saw her video go off
double the pleasure i wish everyone was
back in the room
yeah oh and now we do have multiples
let's see
there she is representative mckinney
see her lips movie representative
mckinney can you hear us and can you
give us a thumbs up
or thumbs down
so uh
i was previously detained uh house bill
passes to be retained at uh
at about eight to seven
testing one two three uh
perfect representative mckinney we can
hear you again
you can hear me yes i can hear you
does she still show up on the bottom
below that
no she just disappeared no that's where
this is yeah
okay so she only has the one just the
video
the one secret square yeah right um
is there something i should be pushing
was that a question representative
mckinney oh you can hear me
oh good okay i'm good thanks
all right we'll go quickly um
finally i think the only the last bill
we have is hcr2
terminating the state of emergency
declared by the governor due to the
noble private uh
coronavirus covit 19.
i would be looking for a motion
representative greed
and i move to retain it's there too
moving to retain hcr2
uh is there a second well second
representative
representative roulard i think i heard
you yes i'll second
um moved and seconded i
would ask representative green to speak
to his motion
yes uh we have another a number of
things happening already
toward attending our state of european
sea uh while we all wish to see
an end there's better ways to accomplish
it
in a way that the spontaneous intended
uh to retain the bell mouth with some
disappointment
away for later if necessary
and for these reasons thank you
representative green are there any
comments
questions on further discussion on house
in current resolution two yes
ah representative smith uh thank you mr
chairman
um hcr 2 is clear
it is well written it does not possess
any structural flaws working on this
over the summer is not going to produce
any meaningful change on the bill
that is the purpose of a motion to
retain
so there really is no reason to do so
with this time
um if there were other purposes for a
motion to retain
um you know those might be accomplished
by doing so at this time but
it would seem to me that we should be
seeking
uh the accountability that goes with
this bill
there are a large number of activists
out in the public who have an immediate
interest in the outcome
of the house's action on this and
postponing that would seem to be a
disservice
to all of the people who've testified
before the committee
and contacted us by email and phone etc
asking us to you know move forward or
not with this bill so retaining it
at this time really doesn't serve
a legislative purpose or the public
purpose so i would urge the committee to
vote no
so that we can make a regular
dispositive motion with this bill today
um thank you are there any other
comments from uh
could you comment later i'm in a zoom
meeting with the committee and we're
about to take a vote
any other comments on hcr2
um the only comment that i will make is
uh i sent you to the
[Applause]
to the letter that was sent to the
committee
from our house clerk
and in that letter
um there were a number of
comments made regarding uh
the appropriateness of um or or the
actions
of house hdr2
and whether it would accomplish the uh
the intention of the sponsors um
i think there are things that we could
work on um
with hdr2 and for that reason i will be
voting
in favor of retaining hcr2
uh any other comments if not i will ask
the clerk paula roll
representative green yes representative
mckinney
yes representative packard
yes representative osborne yes
representative roulard yes
yes representative simon
yes representative wall no
representative lay
representative smith no representative
frost
no representative nutting wong
no representative richards
no representative expedia
no representative hill yes
he said having
uh the vote of eight to seven house
current resolution two is representing
i think that covers us all is another
last vote um
that means i will close the executive
session
um i do have questions for the
committee about the upcoming session
on the 7th 8th and 9th looking through
the
list of work that is going to be brought
up
on those dates i was wondering if
we anticipate uh floor debates
and whether that's been been
[Music]
i would be grateful if we would take the
bills we voted
in opposition to or where we didn't
agree today as well as
um bills that we handled in our last
executive session there were two bills
at that time h bill 156
which was an eight to seven vote and um
age bill 558 which was in each seven
bill
hbill 156 was inexpedient to the
legislate and it was relative
to posting legislative amendments on the
new hampshire legislative
website h bill hb
558 was retained eight to seven
and that established the use of
information technology
in the legislative process so i'm
wondering
are people expecting to fight on either
of those two
on the dates that they come into session
so
um i would say that house bill 558 will
not
have a force returned
is probably the best
opportunity although i also see cacr5
that was a nine to six vote
so those i think it's those two cacr5
and host bill 156 that
may be
um would it be possible for you to get
together
with your caucus and let me know by by
wednesday
i think it'll be helpful since we're all
here right now as the committee of the
whole since it's a small committee
um if we could quickly review those and
figure out if someone wants to speak
to those or any of the ones we disagreed
on today
um we would
we would not be speaking on it
unless there is a intention of
the minority debt to who can speak on it
so so i'm asking
mr chairman
their bills that we don't agree with
the republicans on on the opposition on
on
any of the bills today or the previous
ones mentioned
on h3156 or cacr5
is anyone from our side planning to
speak
on either of those
uh i don't know at this point i don't
know about the 156 but cacr5
is a possibility okay
would it be acceptable for you to get
back to me by noontime tomorrow and
let me know um i'm i'm totally
let me put it another way when would you
be able to get back
to me and let me know when within the
next couple of days
okay yeah we could let you know i mean i
just need to
we just need to check on it
as early as possible yes within the next
girl okay
great so it's just really those two i
think
unless anyone can think of others uh
cacr5
and house bill 156 yep okay
seeing seeing no other
um that hand that was what you were
going to remind me about
right so i don't think that unless you
want anything else
plus the ones today well there's nothing
today
sometimes people have thought we take
retention on the floor
are any of our members planning to have
any floor debates on any of the bills we
had today
um i'll say that if there's a floor vote
on the motion to retain uh the bills we
retained today i'll speak against them
okay that doesn't
right yeah my understanding is that
there's no there's no floor vote on that
but
if it came up i would volunteer okay
okay so it's only those two others so
within the next 48 hours yep
sounds great um anything else than
anyone in the committee
um good work everyone thank you for
getting
here on time and and handling everything
in
expedition's fashion look at that i said
10 45
and it's 10 45 by that clock i'm
actually early by that clock
um with that i will
close the meeting is that right anyone
else no going once going twice
gone thank you